what's happening in ukraine is nothing
new way back in 2008 they used the exact
same playbook they're using right now to
invade a different country the country
of georgia
i'm talking about the 2008 russell
georgian war this war only lasted five
days but every single thing that
happened then is repeating itself in
ukraine today
just like ukraine georgia was once part
of the soviet union just like ukraine
after the fall of the soviet union both
these countries got their independence
and tried starting new they were
cooperating with the west joining
american military drills and trying to
put their soviet days behind them but
for russia that was unacceptable
who did these small insignificant
countries think they were aligning
themselves with the enemy when they were
right at the footsteps of mother russia
the soviet union may have been gone but
the resentment and distrust of america
didn't magically disappear and now here
were some of russia's closest neighbors
all but inviting america in to set up
military bases right on russia's borders
what would america do if russia suddenly
built a military base on the mexican
border it would be unacceptable so
russia made it clear to these countries
stay away from nato keep america out of
your military and then you get to keep
your independence
but if you even try to join nato or if
you become too friendly with america
there will be dangerous consequences
that was the deal
and for a couple of years most of the
ex-soviet countries stuck with it but
then as time passed joining the west
became a little too tempting you see all
this keep nato out stuff had left
countries like georgia and ukraine
vulnerable to russia's influence surely
had their independence but russia still
controlled their politicians and
governments through money and aid but if
they somehow joined nato they could turn
all of that around they wouldn't need
russia's money or protection anymore and
that's where things got ugly because as
soon as these countries started asking
how to join nato or as soon as they
became too american russia saw it as a
direct threat didn't we explain the
consequences here were these tiny
helpless little states doing exactly
what russia told them not to do and the
best way to get these countries back
under russia's control
invade
in the last 15 years russia has used
this exact invasion playbook three times
first it starts with supporting
pro-russian separatists in these
countries separatists are people who
want autonomy who want to turn the land
they live on into their own countries
separate from the actual country they're
living in these separatists would attack
ukrainian and georgian soldiers call for
independence and do everything they
could to cooperate with russia they were
russia's inside guys tasked with causing
chaos and fear and preparing the country
for invasion next russia would carry out
military drills and training inside the
separatist regions they would quietly
sneak in weapons and soldiers pretending
they were just there for some
peacekeeping exercises but in reality
they were amassing weapons and troops
waiting for orders to invade and when
the rest of the world starts pouring
fingers and asking questions
well they would then just make a big
show of withdrawing only leaving a few
reserve soldiers and all their weapons
behind
and with that the stage is sets the
weapons and equipment are on the border
and it's almost time to attack now all
russia needs is an excuse they need a
legitimate reason to send their troops
in and that's where the provocation
comes in
basically russia starts pushing all the
country's buttons trying to get them to
make the first move any move by now
these ex-soviet countries are freaking
out they are sure russia is about to
invade they know they don't have the
weapons or expertise to fight back and
they're doing everything they can to act
first so they play right into russia's
hand whether they push the joint nato
preemptively attack the separatist
rebels or even just suggest an attack
it's all the excuse russia needs almost
immediately after the first act of
aggression russia invades their excuse
always to keep the peace and protect the
people obviously that's what happened in
georgia in 2008 and that's what's
happening right now in ukraine but what
is the endgame obviously georgia is
still an independent country so russia
didn't win the 2008 war rights but what
if winning the war was never their
objective what if russia had a much more
sinister motive than just
re-establishing the soviet union to
understand what this could mean for
ukraine and the rest of the world we'll
have to go back in time
back to when georgia was russia's
biggest headache instead of ukraine back
when the world got a 5 day glimpse and
how they dealt with their rebellious
neighbors in the past
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime with my team subscribe for more if
you want to win a thousand dollars cash
all you have to do is follow me on
instagram at jaketran and you're
automatically entered watch out for fake
accounts i would never message you
asking for money or to invest and this
is russia's invasion of georgia
with the world spiraling into chaos it's
more important than ever to be saving
and investing to build long-term wealth
so that you have a safety net in the
long term the problem is rich people get
access to exclusive investments that
regular people like you and i don't get
access to like investing in early stage
startups for example a very high risk
and equally high reward strategy why are
only rich people able to invest in
startups outdated regulations say you're
too stupid to do so yes it is completely
legal to go bankrupt gambling all your
money away on the lottery it's legal to
gamble all your money away at the casino
and yet if you wanted to invest your own
money into a private company before
they're listed on the stock markets you
can't that's why they have the
accredited investor role a fancy term
that means you need to be a millionaire
or be making over 200k a year to invest
in private startups basically the
government is saying you already have to
be rich to get rich this really
frustrated a guy named jesse so after
years of maneuvering through convoluted
regulations he was finally able to
launch sweater the vc fund that allows
anyone to invest in early stage startups
without already being rich without being
accredited that means anyone can
download the sweater app from the app
store sign up for free and be able to
invest in the most exclusive asset class
in the world venture capital with a
minimum investment of 500 and no cap
it's accessible to practically everyone
the money you invest gets pulled
together with other sweater members
which allows sweater to put together
competitive vc deals sweater's
experience investment team would then
invest that money into emerging tech and
product startups poised for growth
companies you'll see in your everyday
life vc investing is a long term mindset
invest in weights just like you would
with your 401k or ira many startups take
10 years or more to reach an acquisition
or ipo and with sweater you can continue
growing your position through weekly or
monthly recurring contributions the
sweater front is also evergreen meaning
that your venture portfolio never stops
growing as they continue to invest
you'll get broad private market exposure
to the most innovative venture-backed
companies before they go public what's
cool is that sweater literally just
launched so if you want the chance to
join sweater as a founding member so you
can get in at the starting value of the
fund go to
sweaterventures.com to join the sweater
party and invest now that's
sweaterventures.com jake tran with the
link below thanks to sweater for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
georgia has a long history of wanting to
be their own country and in 1918 they
actually managed to declare independence
from the russian empire but fast forward
three years and the red army invades
forcing georgia and its neighbor
abkhazia to become soviet republics
unlike today the land that formed part
of the soviet union wasn't really
divided into independent countries
georgia wasn't its own country with its
own president and its own laws or any of
that it was more like a state that
formed part of the great soviet union
and in this state of georgia there were
two groups of people who didn't really
like being grouped together with the
rest the south of stations and the
occasions they didn't feel like georgia
really represented their people so while
still under the soviet union's control
they did their best to separate
themselves from the rest of the georgian
republic
fast forward to the near end of the
soviet union and south ossetia finally
declares its independence from georgia a
year before the ussr falls but then the
soviet union goes down and now all of
these states that were part of the ussr
have to figure out where their borders
are who controls what and how this
independence thing was going to work
so georgia's new government comes and
says hey we're going to be independent
from russia and we're taking to south
ossetians and occasions with us you guys
are way too small to be countries of
your own anyway so just join georgia and
we'll look after you
that was the pitch but the south
ossetians and occasions weren't having
any of it in their minds they were
nothing like the georgians they spoke a
different language had different
traditions and they actually preferred
life under the soviet union where they
could govern themselves so they went to
war
[Music]
and for the next couple of years the
occasion separatists fought tooth and
nail to get out of georgia obviously
with russia desperately holding on to
its soviet legacy it did everything it
could to support the occasions against
this new independent georgia but in the
end the fighting didn't really go
anywhere so in 1994 both sides agreed to
a ceasefire and for the next decade or
so things were pretty quiet sure there's
the occasional rebel attack and
relations between the three groups are
pretty tense but nothing near a
full-scale war that is until georgia
starts talking about joining nato with
all the separatists on their doorstep
georgia started thinking maybe asking to
join nato would be worth the risk that
way they would have backup in case
another war broke out but to russia that
wasn't an option if georgia joined nato
who would be next ukraine oh no they
were gonna have to teach georgia and all
the ex-soviet countries a lesson
so russia starts pumping money to the
separatists by 2008 almost all the south
ossetians carried russian passports and
russia paid for more than two-thirds of
their yearly budget and while all of
this was going on georgia knew it was
playing with fire but they still thought
they could join nato before anything
really bad happened the only problem was
they didn't realize how quickly russia
could attack
[Music]
between april and august 2008 relations
between georgia and the separatists went
even more sour than usual according to
russia georgia was assembling troops to
invade epcasia so in retaliation russia
starts riling up their separatist
supporters a couple weeks later a
georgian drone gets shot down over
epcasia georgia blames the russians now
things are really heating up
may 2008 unarmed russian soldiers
interrupt casia to quote fix a railway
line end quote georgia calls it an act
of aggression and the tension builds
even more things go back and forth like
this for months
using all the confusion and fear as
cover russia had already moved their
soldiers into position in south ossetia
and eptasia now all they needed was for
georgia to take the first swing
august 1 2008 an ied near south
ossetia's capital explodes as a georgian
police vehicle drives by in response the
georgian army starts firing at south
ossetian rebel bases checkmate russia
has its excuse to invade and the game
was over for georgia before it even
began
almost immediately a full-scale war
breaks out it starts with small battles
across the georgia and south ossetian
border but as the days go by georgia
keeps rolling in more and more soldiers
outgunned in out man the south ossetians
ask russia for hell and on august 7 2008
the kremlin officially joins the fight
the next five days put georgians through
hell the russians are dropping bombs
assembling troops and sending fighter
jets over the georgian capital
russia's military isn't even fully
engaged yet and the georgians are
already feeling the heat they're begging
for nato and america to step in to
support them and put russia back in its
place but nothing happened
the best the west can offer is calls for
a ceasefire for five days russia
decimated georgia stopping its attack
just 30 miles from the country's capital
it was clear who the winner was gonna be
george's military couldn't compete with
russia and without the west's help
georgians were ready to accept defeat
but then on august 12th just five days
after launching their attacks the
bombing stops the tanks that were on
their way to the capitol come to a
standstill on the side of the road
russia had proven its power and it cost
georgia millions now that georgia was on
its knees it was time to negotiate for
the next few days the presidents of
russia georgia and france meet to talk
details russia has shown georgia exactly
what will happen if they don't cooperate
and the georgian president was more than
happy to negotiate for peace in the end
the two countries agreed to a six-point
ceasefire plan the first four points
were pulled up by the french president
and were the usual stop fighting go back
to your bases kind of thing but the last
two points they were added by russia and
were non-negotiable
one russian peacekeeping troops would be
allowed access to south ossetia ab asia
and parts of georgia and two the
independence of the separatist regions
in georgia would need to be discussed in
the future
august 16th
both countries sign the agreement and
russia starts withdrawing some of its
troops ten days later the russian
president officially recognizes south
ossetia and epcasia as independent
states
russia was never looking for peace after
the war it wasn't looking for compromise
it was showing the world if you don't
give me what i want i'll go to war and
take it anyway and where was america in
the west in all of this according to
them their hands were tied
you see when the war in georgia started
the first thing the world expected was
america and the west to step in but as
the days went by and nothing happened
people started asking why wasn't this
kinda america's job upholding democracy
and independence and all that
unfortunately georgia just wasn't
important enough according to one
researcher no one was willing to go to
war for georgia because it was a time in
which no one really wanted to provoke
russia
no one wanted to anger russia over a
small insignificant country with no oil
no strategic importance and no powerful
military and the reason the whole war
had started george's claims it was going
to join nato yeah that was a pipe dream
too
after seeing what happened to georgia
almost none of the other nato countries
could agree to let them join just in
case the same thing were to happen to
them
now more than 10 years after the war
georgia is still not a part of nato
russia still controls more than 20 of
the country and that peace agreement the
two countries signed in 2008 it's not
worth the paper it's written on
more than a decade later russia is still
waging a hybrid war against georgia in
south ossetia and up asia russian
soldiers move the physical borders the
barbed wire and fences a little further
into georgia almost every week
it's gone so far that some georgians
backyards have now become independent
territory
separatists are still kidnapping
georgian citizens and the rest of the
country they live in constant fear of
another invasion
this time they know for a fact that
america and the west won't lift the
finger to help and there would be
nothing stopping russia from taking
control
[Music]
here's the thing america's lack of
reaction in 2008 had given russia the
metaphorical green light they'd invaded
georgia killed civilians and then
negotiated a ceasefire agreement that
gave them a major upper hand all without
america lifting a finger
if they could get away with that how
much more could they really do
they could just as easily invade ukraine
moldova belarus and all their other
neighbors
obviously the invasion wasn't serious
enough to get the west involved so
russia could just go right on doing what
it wanted while america minded its own
business because even though russia
didn't technically win the war in
georgia they had gotten what they wanted
in effect they'd made it clear who
really called the shots in eastern
europe the same thing goes for today
even if russia doesn't win in ukraine
they're probably still going to come out
on top russia has already declared the
disputed separatist regions of ukraine
as independent just like they did in
georgia if ukraine manages to win or the
war ends in a stalemate russia is
probably gonna invade one of its other
neighbors to reassert its power and if
russia wins they could easily use their
victory to threaten other ex-soviet
countries into giving them more control
this win-win situation is a direct
result of the invasion strategy they
perfected in georgia in 2008 a strategy
america and europe could have prevented
if only georgia wasn't such a quote tiny
and insignificant country end quote the
only thing russia didn't plan for was
the unprecedented support of ukraine by
the west
georgia's invasion should have triggered
a massive response from america here was
russia a country with a direct link to
communism invading a democratic nation
and trying to control its government
before 2008 america had gone to war and
got the cia involved in fire glass in
1953 the cia was directly responsible
for the overthrow of iran's
democratically elected prime minister
all because he nationalized the
country's oil industry something iran's
communists supported he wasn't actually
a communist he never claimed to be one
he didn't even seem to like russia all
that much but america still went in and
caused chaos in the name of fighting the
commies
so where was that energy when more than
50 years later georgia was invaded by
russia basically the birthplace of
modern communism unlike iran here was a
direct threat against a democratic
country and america did nothing that's
because everything we know about why
america invades goes to war or carries
out secret operations to overthrow
governments is a lie they tell us it's
to preserve democracy or protect
innocent people but the truth is far
more sinister and in the end all of
those countries where the cia got
involved in local politics almost all of
them changed for the worse
and no country is a better example of
that than iran
iran pretty much went from a west loving
open country to one of america's biggest
enemies in a matter of years
that one act of aggression by the cia
was the first domino to fall in what
would lead to some of the biggest terror
attacks in the world but to understand
just how much damage the cia caused and
why anyone in america would think it was
a good idea to kick a democratic prime
minister out we have to take a deep dive
into iran's history but here's the thing
looking into the cia coup in iran's mean
talking about a lot of stuff that
youtube has a reputation for
demonetizing a video over that's why
we've just released it as a new private
documentary only available to members of
this channel
once you sign up you'll also have
unlimited access to all of our other
documentaries on the release of the bin
laden papers every gepstein mkultra the
cia's mind control project and monsanto
the company that owns the world's food
supply channel members have been loving
the videos these are the kind of things
they should be teaching you in
university about how the world works but
unlike university you get all of this
for just five dollars a month and
there's a refund policy too unlike most
youtube memberships so if you join and
you don't think it's worth it email us
within your first month of joining and
we will personally refund you for your
first month after your first month
there's no refund because a few bad
apples decided to abuse this refund
policy pause the video and click that
join button below right now
have you heard about this conflict
before ukraine i definitely did not so
let me know what you guys thought in the
comments below if you're new here this
is one of the biggest channels on
youtube for documentaries on money power
war and crime we make multiple
documentaries just like this one every
single week for free so if you enjoyed
this one click that subscribe button
below remember you can follow me on
instagram for a chance to win a thousand
dollars every single week we've already
had multiple winners and you can follow
me at jake tran that's gonna wrap it up
stay dangerous out there and i will see
you guys in the next one
[Music]
you